the coronavirus has hit all European
countries and it has put all our health
systems under pressure but some
countries in particular Italy and Spain
have been hit earlier and much harder
than others support from the European
Union and from other EU countries is
crucial to help them cope with the
pandemic our European solidarity can
save lives what hospitals in these
countries need most are respiratory
ventilators I'm grateful to Denmark
which will send ventilators and a mobile
field hospital to Italy it comes just
days after teams of European doctors and
nurses from Romania and no way were
deployed to Italy through the European
Union civil protection mechanism further
support will come from the European
Union we are creating a strategic
reserve of ventilators to send them to
the countries that need the most Romania
has offered to be the first country to
host this EU reserve the first 150
ventilators paid by the European Union
budget are in production and will be
dispatched to the countries most in need
immediately we're also buying together
through joint procurement ventilators as
well as protective equipment such as
masks in this unprecedented crisis we
are stronger together in the European
Union